so let's dig in on
some basic things why are you pursuing
hydrogen
and not batteries because it seems like
batteries
are in every laptop every phone and the
advances in batteries have been
pretty spectacular i own the the 16th
roadster ever made
i've been a fan of tesla since the
beginning i've owned every one of their
cars
uh and though the battery life on those
has been spectacular and the prices have
gotten cheaper and cheaper why would you
jump off the battery train and go on
hydrogen i don't understand
yeah so actually what people don't know
is niko is the only group in the world
that offers both battery and hydrogen so
we have
we do build these big semi trucks and
they're either hydrogen or battery
electric
and there are two different markets so a
lot of people think that battery
competes with hydrogen it doesn't
they're completely different markets
i'll explain this battery works really
good
up to about 300 miles because you have
you don't need as much weight on
batteries to
you know for the range so you can get
that vehicle to do what you need it to
do and it'll go up to about 300 miles
over 300 miles hydrogen makes much more
sense because of weight
the weight is everything in trucking so
every pound of batteries you have on
your vehicle you're losing about 50
cents per load
per pound up to so in if you have a
truck that weighs 10 000 pounds more
like a battery does compare to hydrogen
then you're gonna lose up to five
thousand dollars on every load you do
every day
if you're at full gross weight wait why
is that i don't understand
that is that because the weight of the
batteries degrades the energy usage or
because i'm getting charged
to uh by weight or there's a cap on
how much weight a truck can have
explained that you might understand
exactly so trucks have a cap on weight
80
000 pounds so if your truck weighs let's
say twenty thousand pounds
that means you have you have sixty
thousand pounds in in in
essentially you freight you can move
with the trailer right
so but if your truck weighs thirty
thousand pounds then you only got you
know you got fifty thousand so you lost
ten thousand pounds of cargo you can
move
well that ten thousand pounds of cargo a
lot of times gets charged if you're
talking about like pork or whatever else
or heavier
or drinks you can get charged 50 cents a
pound
so it's a huge problem because you're
losing 50 cents a pound yeah you're
losing
you're losing you're losing money and
revenue on every load so
hydrogen does not make sense in every
situation it's only a very
narrow window and that narrow window
happens to be a trillion dollar industry
that's
that is weight sensitive loads long
range
what we call over the road freight so
that's moving stuff from state to state
weight sensitive would be the trucks are
being filled to the brim
as opposed to like maybe a fedex truck
may not be filled to the brim it's
filled with it whatever's got to be
there tomorrow so
it might only be built filled fifty
percent or if you're transporting cars
maybe they only take up fifty percent of
the volume
but something that could fill a complete
volume would be beer
or food or milk or something correct
exactly or there's two things that they
call in
trucking weight out and freight out okay
so freight out means you could have like
toilet paper in there and you have no
more room and it doesn't matter because
you're you're you're 30 pounds lighter
than capacity anyways or 30 000 pounds
and no one cares battery makes a lot of
sense for that
but when you start putting heavy loads
like drinks like anheuser-busch or beer
or food or
or milk or anything else weight becomes
a major problem and that's where
hydrogen
makes a lot of sense now here's the key
to hydrogen
hydrogen up until like two years ago
until nicola came along until we really
changed the whole thing
hydrogen would have never worked it was
too expensive we started at 16
a kilogram which is like five times more
than you would with
with our three whatever a kilogram
drive a truck eight miles so would that
drive like a normal car like five times
that or
ten times a normal car a kilogram will
give you like 40 miles got it
so a kilogram 16.8 miles is two dollars
a mile
yeah crazy your own bankrupt yeah so now
now what we did is we've been able to
drive hydrogen down to under four
dollars a kilogram we're about three
dollars a kilogram of hydrogen now
so all of a sudden those economics now
make sense you're cheaper than diesel
you know you're down below that 30 cent
per mile mark on on fuel so now it makes
total sense to
to drive hydrogen and hydrogen is zero
emission how did you do that how did you
get from 14 to three
is there some special sauce there yeah
very simple it's all about it's about
standardization so it's like a phone
right when apple makes a phone they'll
make 25 million or 100 million of the
same thing
yeah so uh in america right now there's
no two hydrogen stations that were
actually developed on the same platform
they're all
they're all engineered from the ground
up separately so it's like your cost is
outrageous and they have to
but there's no standardization so we we
developed the first ever standard
hydrogen station that can be produced in
the thousands
and that's the key is you just drive the
cost down so that takes if you make a
thousand of these instead of requesting
50 million i heard to make a hydrogen
station is that about right right now
okay one yeah so a huge station for semi
trucks it would be
50 now we've got it down below 15. so
this is the equivalent in the tesla
operating system or the tesla world of
the supercharger network correct
yeah very similar to that um but we
don't ever build on speculation so tesla
goes out and puts
these chargers all over the place for
everybody we don't so nikola what we do
is we sell the customers that go to
point a to point b
every single day and they they go back
and forth
so that's what the the anheuser-busch dl
is
exactly so you put a station on that one
route and you never have to worry about
if there's trucks to fill there they're
going to fill 24 7
on that route every single day and
that's where all the money is
and so that 800 million dollar deal how
is that staged they they
they pay have they paid you any of that
it's a letter of intent i'm just curious
the
the name of the class and why are they
it's in contract or yeah it's in
contract but we have to so what we have
to do is
they pay per mile so we allow them to
run our trucks we cover all the hydrogen
costs we cover everything
and they pay about a dollar a mile and
that's how we make our money and so
here's here's the way it works
when peterbilt sells a truck they're
going to fifteen thousand dollars in
profit on that truck when nikola sells a
truck we can make
almost a quarter million a profit per
truck that means they have to sell
20 times somewhere around there we make
20 times more money per truck we sell
than peterbilt does
than our competition and that's because
we own the hydrogen we own the oil
but it's not real oil it's zero emission
fuel and that's the key to hydrogen is
is you own the network
and hydrogen the tank's empty
and you don't have the weight so that's
the reason why you have this big
advantage
on the volume the sort of max load
routes well even like even our even our
hydrogen if you have 60 kilograms that's
only like 120 pounds you know it's like
very light it's a
60 kilograms is more energy than a
than essentially having 15 000 pounds in
batteries with tesla so
that's how i mean you're talking 120
pounds compared to 15 000 pounds or 10
000 pounds